as you know housing is getting more
expensive it's pricing many people here
in southern Nevada out of an affordable
place to live in fact here we're short
about 85 000 affordable units but there
is some Hope on the horizon Laura
negretti joins us live to talk about a
couple of new affordable housing
projects good morning
good morning guys yes that's right
earlier in the morning I told you about
a senior living facility now we're
talking about a brand new it's a 10 unit
affordable Workforce housing we're in
another unit here this is what it's
going to look like I'm here with Mike
Ballard CEO of Camino Verde group so
okay this is what it is going to look
like when we were over there at the
other property walk us through what was
done here first of all we fixed the
basics we fixed the plumbing and
electrical issues there's oftentimes
sewer issues at every property and then
we put in new hardware put in a hard
countertop we put in nice flooring we
clean up the walls oftentimes there's
holes in some of the walls those types
of things differently modernizing it now
we were talking to about who is really
for the Outreach here for who this will
benefit yeah so this is for Workforce
housing for folks working in the north
strip or the Convention Center District
it is um
you know just providing a place that's
potentially walkable for them to walk to
work
great thank you and then as far as how
people can apply and what it is going to
be the figures here if you can share
that information with us as well yeah
you can go to our website you can also
call our property manager call our
company we have and then it's also on
apartments.com so you can look there as
well but we have 14 buildings in the
area 140 units and there's a few
vacancies in every property thank you so
much definitely a like we're saying a
much needed resource here coming to the
area Laura negretti 8 news now back to
you guys time to get your applications
and Lauren thank you for that